Please clarify what we thought you said about not Hodgkin's lymphoma and stayed away from medial lymphatic lymphatic muscles.
Patient is currently doing low dose IPT chemo and the clinic has recommended massages to doc detoxify.
Your insight is valid.
Okay, so you think about doing lymphatic detox to help with detoxification pathway.
So understand the whole detoxification process.
So from the farthest away from the detox exit would be the tissues.
So your tissues, so your cells, let's start there.
In your cells, you will detox waste from the cell, the normal waste from normal metabolic activity,
waste from like if your gluttonyone pathway is neutralizing, oxidizing agents and then it will spew them out
through the cell membrane into the extracellular space.
So waste from the cells gets spewed out into the extracellular spaces.
That's the spaces between the cells.
And then the things move from there solely through motion of contract, you contract the muscles motion of gravitational forces on you and that they move towards these open ended vessels like like sewers in your street that are called lymphatic vessels.
So lymphatic vessels then are just open ended vessels throughout your tissues that then pick up this and the waste will then be carried through the lip vessels and the full lip vascular system.
There are check valves, so check valves allow things to go in one direction and then don't allow things to go backwards.
So how things move through the lymphatic system is solely through the action of muscles and through gravity.
So it takes forces physics to move something things will stay in and things that stay was only go into motion and motion is exerted upon them, so exercise is so important.
Now, so if you want to detox you have to move your body you have to exercise you just have to contract muscles motion is life.
So contracting your muscles moving even you know people that I'm you know take care of over the years that I can't I'm in a bed and I'm confined to a bed well if you could start writing the alphabet with your toes moving your legs.
Getting some motion in your body any motion is beneficial to move fluid through your lymphatic tissue.
Now what is it we have to be careful about the cancer is that let's say let's say you have lymphoma so you have cancer in some lymph nodes so do you want to massage at that site.
So would you possibly be pushing a circulated tumor cells and having them circulate through your body.
Well, the answer is yes, that is possible, but typically circulated to ourselves that go through your lymphatic system.
Most of the time be carried back well anything goes through the lymphatic system will ultimately be carried back to your venous system that then it circulates through your liver to then through phase one phase two and phase three in the liver.
It detoxified and put into bile and then put into the first part of the small attested that hopefully go through your attestinal tract and exit into the toilet.
But can that be a possible way that cancer could spread well I would say you know you just think from from a functional perspective and it's yes if you're massaging the site of the cancer.
So let's say you have Hodgkin's lymphoma and you have one you know lymph node that has cancer in it.
It's your neck area I'd say you should stay away from that that I've said over and over again people with breast cancer you should probably stay away from the site of the breast.
I mean you can still massage the arm when you have lymphatic stasis in let's say I'm breast cancer in the left arm and you have metastasis to the axillary lymph node in the left.
Can you still massage do some soft tissue massage lymphatic drainage massage on the left arm sure should you do it in an axillary area where you have metastasis probably done so just use some common sense on.
You know what you know what a basically be aggravating the site of the cancer nor do you want to be you know manipulating the cancer itself pushing on the cancer aggravating the cancer where it could possibly you know damage the wall around the cancer that your bodies hopefully try to create the wall off the cancer.
And or creating excess circulating to ourselves to be expelled by that tumor pass you don't want to just aggravate the cancer so I don't think there's any benefit to just just manipulating the cancer itself physically pushing on a tumor.
I don't think there's any benefit to that one so ever so I would just say stay away regardless whether it's lymphoma or it's breast cancer you know whatever cancer you have to stay away from you know massaging that site of the cancer that's what they should be teaching and I know that they do because I used to have a massage therapist that went through extra training to massage cancer patients and that's what they instructor to do to stay away from the cancer itself.
You don't want to aggravate the cancer it can become irritated you could possibly disperse more circulating to ourselves so just think of it that way it pretty much common sense to just stay away from it but doing any other lymphatic massage is fine.
And certainly understand how your lymphatic system works normally you're not getting the soldiers to move lymph you are using muscles to move lymph exercising to move lymph also this is where when you're doing chemotherapy or even IPT type chemo low nose chemo using other things to help you support those detox pathways.
IE sweating through the use of sonas using coffee enemas to stimulate phase one two three of the liver castoral packs over the liver to do the same thing you know the more things that you could do to support downstream pathways that better you could do most of the time in a person you know has not had a massage for a long time it goes to get a massage that they can have a detox reaction I had that one.
When I got a massage because I was never used to getting massage when we went on a vacation runs several years ago and this is what I wasn't doing the greatest I thought well this would be good for me to get a massage well you know stupid me I didn't drink enough water and I felt sick the rest of my you know for the first couple days of my time away so that was kind of spoiled by vacation and it's because I basically stimulated
the tissues to be to the lymphatic system to receive a lot of toxins from the tissues and basically overwhelmed by liver detox pathways.
In a sense I basically it was a herxide reaction because I produce too many toxins in my bloodstream then my liver phase one two three could get rid of you know and a greater rate than they could get rid of I didn't have any coffee.
I didn't have any coffee and I'm a kid with me that would have helped me a lot I didn't do have castor oil packs or how packs to go over my liver at the time again I was on my vacation that would have helped so I just had a drink a ton of water and try to flush this out but any time you know go back to the detox the seven phases of detox and understand those seven phases of detox we've got to be making sure that everything downstream from that lymphatic massage
is open as humanly possible or you could just make yourself sicker with any type of massage.